Es war eine unglaublich besondere Nacht, wissen Sie
, die Wahrheit ist für diejenigen von uns, die
an der Kampagne teilgenommen haben, eine
der vielleicht ergreifendsten bedeutungsvollsten
Nächte der gesamten Kampagne war nicht einmal
Grant Park, sondern als wir nach Iowa gingen, weil
wir es wussten  Dass er
tatsächlich Präsident werden könnte, war
davor eine völlig unwahrscheinliche Bewegung im
Wahlkampf, aber als wir Iowa gewannen, dachten wir,
Sie wüssten, was wir tatsächlich tun könnten
, und das war irgendwie fast,
obwohl ich es nicht nennen möchte  Überraschung,
aber ich wollte immer wirklich
versunken sein, als die allgemeinen
Wahlen zu Ende gingen, hatten wir eine
Erwartung, ich glaube, als
die Wahlen um die Woche herumliefen, war mein
Zwilling und aber trotzdem im Fernsehen zu sehen, dass
die Netzwerke waren  Ich nenne ihn, dass er
das Rennen für Barack Obama projiziert. Ich meine, Tränen sind
über uns alle gespült, es war nur
eine dieser besonderen Nächte und dann das
Leben von jedem, der an dieser
Kampagne teilgenommen hat, ganz ehrlich im Leben von
Ihnen  das amerikanische Volk und Menschen
auf der ganzen Welt
Sie